let me ask you sort of a personal
question for me do you think it's
possible
do you think it's useful to do a podcast
conversation with somebody like David
Duke
or somebody
this was somebody that everybody knows
so it's not like you're giving a
platform to somebody that's a hidden
um
member of the KKK or like uh it's a sort
of putting a a pretty face on some dark
ideas but everybody knows and so now
you're just exploring you're sitting
across the table maybe not in his case
um maybe somebody who's an active KKK
member sitting across from a person that
literally hates me
Flex I think that's fascinating too I do
too I I think uh so long as what you are
doing
is not boosting someone so taking an
obscure figure
and making that figure now famous yes uh
but if it's someone who's already
Infamous yeah and it helps us to
understand them and as so long as your
effort
is to ask them tough questions which you
do right you don't you don't give them
all the questions in advance you don't
have limitations on what you can ask so
long as it is a real interview not
pablum then I'm for it what I'm what I'm
against is a softball interview that
allows someone to sound reasonable when
they're not uh but the way I've seen you
do this when you've had figures like
that I won't name who I have in mind but
when I've seen that is I I think that's
I think that's useful because honestly
uh the historian and me and the citizen
in me wants to understand
um my my Jewish grandfather always was
the the first to be against any effort
to suppress anti-semites
because his view was he wanted to know
who they were
and he wanted to know what they thought
so he could be prepared